police in Sweden are trying to catch
brazen thieves who stole two crowns and
an orb owned by the Swedish royal family
the priceless objects date back to the
early 1600s and the suspects got away on
a motorboat Roxana Saberi following the
widening investigation from London
Roxana good morning good morning the
jewels were originally buried with the
royal couple centuries ago but they are
so precious to Swedish heritage that
they were later exhumed they were on
display when they were stolen kicking
off an international manhunt the heist
of the two 17th century crowns and orb
is stunning Sweden police say two
thieves smashed a security case at this
Cathedral near Stockholm on Tuesday
setting off an alarm in broad daylight
when other people were in the building
authorities suspect the burglars then
took off on bicycles a motorboat was on
a nearby lake waiting for them according
to a British witness the two men hardly
jumped on board and it sped off in that
direction over that way police have been
investigating on foot and by boat but
Lake mälar is one of the largest lakes
in Sweden crowded with islands and
surrounded by towns the jewels of king
Karl the ninth and his wife Queen
Christina are national treasures says
Scott Selby co-author of flawless inside
the largest diamond heist in history how
valuable are they the thing is the
priceless but the problem is the thieves
can't sell them as that everybody knows
what they are they're identifying ball
so if the thieves were to melt down the
gold it's about one kilo of gold which
is currently worth about $40,000 if
these jewels are only worth $40,000 it
seems like a big risk for these thieves
to go through all this it is a lot of
risk so that's why the police think this
might be some sort of heist to order
some sort of collector of some sort they
may want these particular items or
perhaps these these have some other
notion of what they can do with these
things such as ransom in then five years
ago another Kings jewels were stolen
from another Cathedral in Sweden police
found them several days later in garbage
bags in a country road
thanks to an anonymous tip normally do
Roxanna thanks there is something about
a robbery like that that's video with a
speedboat everything involving speed
exactly in Sweden